[Music]
wishful thinking
okay sorry about that meeting open right
um there's an apology from chris um
she's back in hospital so
that's not good happy to move madame
chair thank you a second after that
has anybody heard from john mayer
no
all those in favor
again scared okay thank you
um
conflicts of interest i've got a
conflict of interest i guess with a
sculpture when it comes up um
in the landscaping budget
so we'll see how we work that when we
get there i have a conflict of interest
with regard to 6.2 please madam chair
thank you brent
anyone else
no okay
right so the minutes of the cardboard
tour here with community well 28th of
february
um
just a small correction um
tear under 8.1 it had the word
sculptures instead of sculptors sort of
okay it made interesting reading
other than that um i recommend that the
board confirms the minutes from
21st to february meeting
do i have a second
thank you al seconded by al
all those in favor
aye again
carried thank you
right any matters arising
oh
okay
we have no deputations or presentations
or during business so the first report
then we've got uh grant and hannah rose
is hannah rosen yes there she i know
that's tori
it's just me
okay all right grant so the riverbank
walkway memorial reserve update over to
you
yeah so this is uh the report was put
together following the workshop that we
had um
that neil was
also at from
the rsa
you'll recall last month and it looked
at those
[Music]
it looked at the options that had been
put to the board previously and kind of
looking at how we could actually go
about
recommending this ford
given the fact that we'd noted that
there was some
i guess differences of
how we might go through and actually
treat the road berm in particular
um
so really the report that's in front of
you is kind of looking at that you'll
note that it's um
basically saying that we look at option
c oh sorry chris
let's turn my mind up
bear with me ladies and gentlemen
certainly
is that better
yep what
we can hear you oh okay cool um
so yeah uh just looking at um at option
c which was an extended version of the
option d
um with potential for this project to be
deferred to a future
ltp
you'll note that neil was at the at the
workshop as well so he was quite aware
of what the board was
likely to propose there i'm also
catching up with neil tomorrow
to talk through some ideas that he's got
for the wall as well
so i was going to talk to him about
what the board would be recommending
tonight but i'll
i'll take the reporters read noting that
we did the workshop last month on this
and if you've got any any further
questions on that i'm happy to take them
thank you
any questions anybody
no it doesn't appear to be it all seemed
very straightforward and it was good
that um
the team listened to the fact that we
wanted to have it deferred so i'm happy
to move the recommendation
a b c
d and e
is there a second
thank you brent seconded by brent
um
any discussion
no
i'm happy to move that brent what would
you like to have a word no you're happy
with that okay right no so i think it's
just a good thing that it's deferred
because we certainly can't afford it so
all those in favor
aye
against
carrot thank you
thank you grant
you're welcome
oh i didn't move f did i
uh that's
that's technically for the council to
uh to recommend but the board may wish
to
[Music]
whether um
not you support if you might want to you
might want to note that down as well
but you can take the two separately
i didn't even notice it the first time
so deferred
option cb submit so why is that there as
well doesn't it already say that in the
other bit oh uh yes but that's
specifically for council
recommendation yeah uh because it's a
financial um
it's a financial recommendation
okay so can we can we include that
terror and what we've just done
that'd be all right
yeah
thank you mate hey sorry okay i was
talking to taylor before i'm getting
confused
thank
if you and brent are both happy with
that that's fine
okay
right so moving on then to the food
forest
um
[Music]
grant again do you have your hand up
nibble
no oh yes you have got your hat there's
a little yellow hand in the top left
hand corner you must have pressed a
button
that's it well done
okay i was trying to catch the seagulls
[Laughter]
grant
um yep so the
the cowboy food forest has put forward a
proposal to
to green space to consider
the installation of the shelter at
cowboy food forest um you'll notice that
reading through the report uh after some
feedback that we'd
received from our
from some staff within utilities and
writing it's become apparent that part
of the structure is to look at whether
or not they could install a toilet as
well
we've been back to them
because there was some discussion that
if a toilet goes in there would need to
be some development contributions
applied to the project that they would
have to pay um
there's also some
queries around
the kind of toilet that would need to go
in and
if there's a pump required for that
which
from what i understand speaking with the
with the engineers there would be um
in essence that's got some costs around
it so
i think we're looking at around back
development contributions potentially uh
just shy of ten thousand
uh and am i
sorry are you wanting am i taking
questions as we go
uh
sorry sorry um
there's also the sewer pump itself which
could um potentially cost just shy of
around about 25 000 again these are all
estimates
um
what would be hoped is that gravity
pumping could be an option at the site
however given the placement um the
engineering team wasn't as comfortable
that this could happen again this was uh
information received relatively late on
so we'd need to look further into this
um
so there's there's a little bit of cost
there in terms of what it is that we'd
be looking at if there was the toilet
included
what the staff are actually recommending
um is that we look to
approve the footprint shelter for
the footprint for the shelter
and that we work we continue to work
with the trust around
exactly how a toilet might fit into this
there's some risks there that staff have
noted just around the toilet and
in particular if
this was ever to become a
a council asset and that's just purely
if it was to become an operational
burden to the trust itself
um that would then revert back to
council that's an ongoing issue with
toilets and buildings to be fair
um
but we'd really like to fully assess
what the risk would be in terms of if
the toilet was
put in as part of the shelter
[Music]
there's a bit of work that the trust
would also like to
to do in terms of
receiving further funding for the
project
um at the moment we haven't got a
defined cost structure out for the
project there was some talk about
whether or not it would be um up to
about a hundred thousand dollars um to
do to do the project in its entirety the
trust has currently got fifty thousand
secured from ministry of social
development
um there is a time frame on that money
for the trust to look at spending
um one of the key things for
for the trust is actually the
approval of the kaiapoi to a hilly
community board to put in place the
shelter
the trust have the ability to do this
via the
license to occupy which they have with
the council
um what that sets out is that the
community board has the delegated
authority to approve structures such as
this
and hence why staff have put this this
report up to the board now look i'm i'm
happy to take questions um
further on on that report
i have a question grant um yes i noticed
somewhere in the report that it said
a relationship was being created between
the church
and the food forest so what happened
there because they have got a toilet
there haven't they and it's just over
the road
uh yes so that's um
that's an existing
relationship that they've got where the
people who go to the food forest can
i believe visit the the church itself to
utilize their facilities
that's certainly something that they've
done in the past
okay so there is a toilet nearby then
not 300 meters away because that's not
300 meters away
that was purely just outlining where the
closest public yeah publicly available
uh philip you've got a question
yes uh thank you graeme um could you
confirm that the council has the
authority to remittle what wave
development contributions
bearing in mind this the council do own
the site
uh i'd have to go
and check that to be fair fell because
in the past uh we haven't had the
ability to get that way for some of the
projects that we've done so i'd have to
i'd have to inquire with the development
contributions team i don't know if chris
knows anything further to that
the the council does council laws
elected members
um but our development contributions um
team
uh and these situations have
um
provided us with
um the development contributions policy
which has highlighted the reasons in
which you would want to
um or you can
waive development contributions
and there's a process to be followed to
do that and some criteria
thank you
thank you um al then neville and then
martin
um another option i'm thinking thinking
sheep because i'm a scotsman what why
haven't we why or have we um considered
a a portaloo with either higher or not
higher because you need it there all the
time wouldn't it be a hell of a lot
simpler and cheaper for the trust to buy
portaloo
uh that's that's not an option that i've
discussed uh with email it's not one
that i've um
that i've costed out either uh that
would be something that we'd have to
look into if uh if that was desirable
for the trust
um if i could add l you did mention um
that it would be uh need to be there on
a more permanent basis i think
um the majority of
the need for the
toilet is for the events that they have
down there the education programs that
they have down there which are not run
all the time the general public that use
it and there's a lot of them
if they're going there ken can walk a
little bit further um because it's not
an organized event their main concern is
the children that come down for school
style events and 300 meters away um or
even just across the road um to the
church can sometimes be difficult when
you're in the middle of a lesson trying
to teach kids how to do something and
then suddenly some of them need to go to
the toilet um getting them across the
road and that sort of thing
when you might only have one teacher
looking after the kids is quite
difficult um but a portaloo for those
events absolutely solves their problem
level
thanks jackie look mine's along with
similar lines given that we're in a
world of sustainability and i'd suggest
that the food forest is one of those
places that
certainly is in that uh in that realm uh
wonder if we've looked at a composting
toilet that could go there as a very
fine example
of what you could do
around sustainability and using the food
forest
as a sustainability exercise
and again i know you'd have to talk to
the trust about that
we would thank you neville um
would you like would we like to hear
from brent on that
thanks madam chair i've sent through a
email this morning with regard to some
of these elements with regard to like
for instance the composting toilet so
you actually have to separate
the solids from urine so you actually
have to have two facilities within a
composting toilet and then when it gets
full you then actually have to deal with
it and as a trust it was going to be
somewhat messy to actually deal with
we've been down the track since we found
out last week through the agenda that
we're going to have to
potentially pay for this
uh for this development contribution we
then looked at
electric and gas-fired toilets which
will mean that we wouldn't need to hook
up to sewer
the long term uh again it's something
that we wouldn't really want to do but
if we were forced into a position i
think if we were to as i was just about
to mention in terms of long term
um
this is council owned land and
eventually the food forest because of
the licensed occupy will finish
and it will then be handed over in terms
of the ownership to the
council and subsequently we need to
probably look long term
now that we have the costings from grant
and thanks for that grant for getting
those costings to us
i know that today the msd have uh
provided
to the food secure network some
additional funding i don't know what is
what that is
and what it's for but potentially we
could go back to msd and request
additional funding certainly hooking up
to sewer from the trust's point of view
from the council's point of view is
going to be so much easier
uh the the food forest trust really is
not interested in operating a toilet
we've operated portaloos
before they get very filled very quickly
from
when we run our events and we've hired
them
we did look at one stage trying to hire
one on a more permanent basis but the
cost was just prohibitive because we run
on the smell of an oily rag in terms of
relationship with the church we have
used the facilities
there at times but because
most of our events on a sunday
there is a conflict because they're
running their church services and we're
trying to run an event
i think i hope that covers it
effectively
if we can i think the major issue is the
funding
uh and it would be a matter of us we
don't want to put any pressure on the
council in terms of the rate powers to
actually fund us we are wanting to go
back to msd and other funders to
actually see if we can get uh support
from them and also
we've already been told by a number of
commercial operators in town that are
very willing to support this particular
project and give us a very good deal on
materials and labor
so whilst we said that a hundred
thousand dollars is the
estimated cost of building it inclusive
of the toilet a lot of volunteer labor
and a lot of other things potentially
we'll be able to bring it under that
number
but now that we've seen the development
contribution and potentially the pump
costs of another 35 000 yeah we're going
to have to go back and start reviewing
uh how we can actually
uh get more funding to to cover those
costs
thanks madam chair
thank you grant um martin
thank you madam chair
i'm a little surprised that there's even
been talk of development contributions i
mean those properties pay development
contributions originally and my
understanding is that development
contributions are only when you create a
new lot
so i'm just really surprised that that's
that's come up as an issue
yes because there would be new services
needed to be created to service that um
most of those have been either
disconnected or discontinued so
that would be an addition to the current
system which is considered great
thank you
so
would anyone like move
if i can just make one other comment
madam chair and that is that um
the food forest is certainly gaining a
lot of traction in terms of the numbers
of visitors and certainly the education
programs that we're being asked to run
it's getting more and more of a need
like
even enliven which is a presbyterian
support surfaces come to the food forest
every monday
and they would rather go there than in
fact visit uh cafes and restaurants
they love the the atmosphere so we're
getting a lot more people coming we've
got a lot more education classes this
gazebo
most of the times will not be
educational be mainly people coming and
picnicking that's what people love to do
is come and picnic there and really the
toilet element is is just going to be an
advantageous to everybody that comes and
visits
thanks for that
thanks
brent
i'm happy to move madam chair the
recommendations
thank you al
um is there a seconder
evil neville seconded by neville okay
so do you want to speak to that now uh
no not really we've covered we've
covered it um and i mean we we're
talking about staff investigating
options and and we'll leave it to them
and come back to us with a with some
firmed up plans
very good
neville
yeah look i think the food forest doing
a great job and i think this would be a
great investment for the community so
um let's investigate see where we can
get to
okay any other comments
doesn't seem to be oh philip
i'd just like to say i think it's great
idea the building is not too big a scale
i wouldn't like to see the building
dominating the site and it doesn't and i
think it would be advantageous to
include a toilet for
um organised groups
if that funding can be achieved
so anyhow very supportive
thank you phillip all right so um
all those in favor of 6.2 from a through
to f for those in favor
aye
against no one against carried very good
thank you
all right moving on now to the general
landscaping budget and tori over to you
thank you i think grant stephens is just
going to do an introduction if that's
all right um given this was um a lot of
these his projects and then he'll hand
over to me
yeah good good evening everyone um yeah
as you'll know i used to be the person
that came and talked to you about
general landscaping budgets and how you
might allocate that budget across the
year to projects um we've had a bit of a
shift around in our
green space team with the design and
planning team being created and as part
of that we've had to reshuffle some of
the the workload in there and so um tori
has very kindly taken on you as a board
to look after your general landscaping
project so um henceforth she will be the
person coming in and running the
workshops with you and
writing the reports and and helping you
track that budget spend so um yeah i'll
hand him back to troy to present the
report but um it just wanted to explain
what i guess this transition across to
tory so yeah
thanks grant okay tory
thanks grant uh so the report is to
provide some information
uh on a number of projects uh that i
think grant discussed with the workshop
last november
um and those
the ones that i've included in this
report are the enhancement of the kaipoi
town entrances uh a seat and planting at
the kaipou end of the passchendaele
walkway and the installation of a
raymond herbert sculpture in kaiapoi
um
just to clarify a couple of things
before i take questions and there's been
a little bit of confusion around
the raymond herbert
sculpture which is um item d under the
recommendations um
following discussion with the kaiapoi
arts trust
uh it's preferred that the sculpture is
placed in kai poi and therefore that is
back on the table back on the agenda
tonight for discussion
um
a suitable location for that is is still
being sought the four town entrances
have been looked at as a possible
location but
they're not viewed as being quite um
suitable to it i think the idea is to
the raymond herbert sculpture creates
quite a silhouette and it's it's weird
as it might be better to have a um
quite a an open view of the skyline
behind it to to get the full effect of
the sculpture
so we're still looking at
locations for that
the other
item
just to quickly note is that after the
report was submitted
uh the the project um
the kaipal interpretive panels project
uh which you approved twenty thousand
towards
at a previous meeting is nearing its
completion however we need
300 more dollars to complete that
project above the 20 000
so we're also requesting the approval of
an extra 300 towards that
from the general landscaping budget
tonight
so i'm happy to take questions uh if i
as i say some of these
a lot of the research has been
done in the in the past by grant so if i
can answer them i might have to refer to
grant stevens a little um i hope that's
all right i'll put my hand up and grant
can take over
thanks tori that's great
so any questions
i'll just say the signage um we've got
one sign up already
um
and there's another
two two or three i can't remember now
that are almost ready they've got all
the information so they're not far away
so it would be really nice to get that
um
i wondered if you wanted to talk at all
this might not be the time to do it but
i'll mention it anyway of a location now
that it's back in cairo
of a location for the sculpture and i
have to say i was very surprised when i
saw d that um the 10 000 installation
costs were coming out of our landscape
budget i naively thought that
the same
process would be used
after the installation of the andrew
drummond sculpture on the riverbank
where the council absorbed the costs i
thought that was going to be
like that for all of the sculptures in
the future so i feel a bit embarrassed
that um here we are now it's ten
thousand dollars that has to come out of
our budget
but anyway um
you can argue against that if you want
to um but yeah um it has been suggested
that maybe down at karaki would be a
good place because it's quite a well
frequented place i don't know what
everyone thinks about that
but we can discuss that later if you
like
neville
and then brent
uh thanks madam chair um a couple of
things in here yes
i i am i'm very pleased that sculptures
um coming to kawaii and
one of the areas that i uh thought may
have been a great area for it was if we
approach the river town villas the wee
triangle
that uh beside the railway there that's
just a very vacant piece of grass
um and i know that they talked about uh
putting something in there
some time ago and it's just a
just a bit of a barren piece
in the middle of the air putting a
sculpture would be would look quite
sharp i think just as for for
consideration for nothing more than that
um
and i notice under g
approves allocation of three three
thousand two hundred dollars towards
passchendaele seats and plants what is
that actually for
um given the rsas are actually putting
seats in fact i'm personally building
them for them to um to go in there is
this
different what's the
torii probably answer that one if you
like um
the
so our understanding from the rsa was
that they had one thousand dollars to
put
towards the seat as opposed to
um
i guess providing
anything like everything that around
that um and that they wanted
um at the passion down trust me they
discussed a seat but also a tree and a
little bit of amenity planting behind um
so
i guess this was um around that
covering that additional cost um
yeah as you say we're aware that um
you've been doing some work with
actually to actually create that so we'd
anticipate that that
um that price potentially um may be
lower than that but we weren't entirely
sure so we've kind of put what we would
anticipate it to be um if it was any
savings from that that would just go
back into the budget um anything that
wasn't spent on that seat um and
planting
can i just
hear just a quick comment on that i just
wonder what that particular piece could
lay on the table given that they're
actually funded by the rsas at the
moment
um
and um need to get through the first
step before we get to the next one i
accept what grant's saying about the
fact that um you know if it's there we
don't have to use it but um
can i just um make a comment
that um
when this request originally went
through was quite some time ago before
the wood
or
or any work had been made on the
benches
and
the request went to both rangiora ashley
community board and came to kaapoy and
just to let you know that rangiora has
actually
allocated three thousand two hundred
dollars towards their side
so
you may not need
this amount at all because i think we
will probably have sufficient unless
you want to concentrate on the planting
area and look at
finding a tree or something along those
lines
thank you kay
brent you had a question
thank you madam chair um
in terms of the entrance ways one thing
that bug is a bug bearer for me is
travelling through to rangiora and the
overhead bridge on smith street and how
appalling
the ground
areas are there or the garden areas
i'm only agreeing with tori in terms of
the raymond herbert sculpture should be
in a prominent place and with virtually
no background and whether or not there
was an opportunity to find
an area on the overhead bridge
so as when you're traveling
into christchurch you'll see it as you
go underneath that overhead bridge and
also it might be an opportunity for us
to landscape some of those areas
between
kaiapoi and rangiora on that overhead
bridge i know it's probably
waka kotahi land but uh it certainly
doesn't
look good when it comes when you come
into chiropod
thanks madam chair
so brent do you mean the actual
overbridge
there or there abouts so as when you you
can actually see it uh as you're driving
under the over bridge or in fact when
you're traveling towards rangiora you'd
see it on the way through
yeah
is that a possibility grant
uh we'd have to have some reasonably
serious conversations with waka kotahi
um
just in terms obviously that's quite a
an
important busy intersection so um they
don't tend to like putting just what may
be seen as a distraction in those
areas especially as it does also have a
spinning so that the whole tree spins is
not a static element
so
i would envision that they would
probably have some quite serious
concerns around locating it
um there
we can certainly ask the question
i think you'd have a good argument with
the one on the other side you know
what's it called the big ground wall
that spins all the time
it's right by the motorway
so you could use that as a defense
um
what is it what's it called
fanfare fanfare that's right there's all
those little fans going
um
okay all right well look um
i'm prepared to move
um
i'm prepared to move a to j
i don't see anything wrong with moving g
um if i mean if the money's not spent
we're going to get it back
yeah okay so i'll test the waters then
um i'll move
from a through to j do i have a second
i'll second that madam chair if you'd
like
right thank you brent so seconded by
brent
um
they're all good things i'm really
heartened that no one seems to think
that
10 thousand is a lot of money for the
installation of the raymond herbert
sculpture and all the other um they're
all things that we want to get done and
you know get on with so
um i think there's
quite a lot of work been put into this
and it will be good to see it all
happening especially the town entrances
project and that sculpture
brent do you want to comment
thank you madam chair i'm all in favor
of making kayaking more beautiful and uh
this approval for the money to be spent
is going to help that process so
all in favor thank you
any other discussion
neville
thanks madam chair look i'm in favor of
all this i've no problem with the 3200
being left in there and i mean you know
once you put it in there i'm sure it'll
spin um
the sculpture
in the motorway area would frighten me
number one they do not like putting
anything on the side of the road and
what would worry me is that we get tied
up in bureaucracy
um to get it established and i think
that that would be possibly a two-year
exercise to get it standing in a place
on on wakakatahi land
the other problem that i have is that
the town entrances and bridges are
absolutely disgusting
and i would really hate to put a lovely
sculpture on the entrance to um
on wakakatahi land that we cannot
maintain that would really really bug me
more than it would it going
unfortunately i should sound constantly
away from an entrance and somewhere of
bitter significance um
and i'm
i've got an absolute open mind on where
that could be
so i think that it's um
i think that it's very important all i
can say is knowing the engineering and
uh
and how much concrete you have to put
around the bottom of a plymouth to
actually stop the wind blowing it over
good luck with ten thousand dollars
because uh you'll be very very lucky if
we sport has enough cement to supply to
hold it up
thank you neville
right so oh al you wanted to say
something yeah just briefly um
uh adding on from what neville said um
and brent about the um
smith street and the approaches it all
it needs to go in a place where people
can stop and walk up to it and i think
that apart from walking you're not
wanting the distraction factor i can't
see you can put it anywhere
there particularly where you'll be able
to you need you need an off-road
lay-by like um fanfare's got where
people can stop and walk up and touch it
excuse me a moment
i just had to turn the tv off um okay um
i don't know where i am
i've moved we've moved in yep we're
waiting to move it right so a through to
j so we have i
seconded by bren all those in favor
i
against
carried
okay thank you
it would be nice to see those motorways
cleaned up they are disgusting they're
absolutely appalling it's almost worth
getting us getting
together with a wheelbarrow and some
spades it would only take 10 minutes
anyway
can i just comment on that um
and i don't know whether it's the case
here but
um the the blindside road um was under
um is under a wakata kataki um
contractor who didn't know that they had
the responsibility of um keeping that um
moan and sprayed which is what they do
until they keep rangiora beautiful got
directly in touch with them and they
realize that i think they're called g
gde for some gh i don't know what they
were called they so
they immediately apologized and started
to maintain line side roads so
has anyone explored whether who in fact
what contractor from
he is responsible for this says someone
contacted wakataki and asked
because it could be exactly the same
outfit
no i i did email someone at wakakotahi
and had a reply and she insisted that it
was the council's job
so then i spoke to joanna she insisted
it will
tell his job that's where it ended
well i guess that in
in that instance that
you could have a uh
a clean up um from the community to get
out there and do it because i agree
absolutely poor
interest
chris
um
if you leave it leave it with me and
i'll go and ask the questions again
because um i i do get frustrated in
situations where um something seems to
be in no man's land someone will be
responsible for it and it will be in
someone's contract um we just need to
actually find out i do know that joanne
did um
talk to
nzta about it and and i saw the
correspondence that you had as well
jackie
i do know that someone's done some
spraying recently but they've sprayed
some rather um tall weeds and the weeds
are now standing dead um in terms of
community going in there and doing it
themselves i highly recommend against
that um it's a very very um
fast moving area with lots of different
lights and the traffic management around
getting community groups to do work and
there would be um quite expensive um
and probably not the right thing to do
so
leave it with me and i'll go and have a
chat with joanne and jared again and see
if i can um
push it along a little bit i might come
back to you and tell you absolutely
nothing more than i've already told you
but i can only try again
great thank you chris
all right moving on so now we're up to
6.4 road naming line developments
limited and scott
is there somewhere
are you with us scott
she's snuck out for a cup of tea
sorry i'm here sorry there's not here i
just had to get my
i had to get my um things right sorry
about that um so good evening um ladies
and gentlemen um
so
basically my report tonight receipts the
decision
um to prove two new road names as part
of the silver stream subdivision and
kaipoi
um the land have been developed as part
of stage 8a which is currently known as
56 italy terrace
um so basically the the developers
chosen two names for for the road naming
and they've come from the list of
pre-approved road names
and i take it all have the opportunity
to read the report and i will welcome
any questions you have thank you
thanks scott um i'd just like to point
out that i was driving around there
yesterday and there's actually a penny
street and i see penny is still on the
list
so um it's been used oh okay
you need to come off yeah yeah
okay
i'll make another um
i was a bit disappointed i mean looking
at this they've obviously just grabbed
hold of the list and gone to the top two
b's you know
bestings and big they were just about
the first two on the list i did have a
look at the list and i'm thinking that
maybe there was a more suitable name um
knowing that district reasonably well
and there is one waverly was the name of
the house that um williams has lived in
on the corner of mill road which isn't
that far away
um i wondered if waverly might be
more suitable than
bestings and beg not that i have
anything against the bastings family or
the beg they're both families in kyopa
but not necessarily to do with this part
of cardboard but that's by the by
neville and then martin
thanks madam chair scott i i noted in
this um report and it's been in there um
uh just about all the times that we've
we've got these reports that uh manufa
um have no interest
and i'm not quite sure that that's
entirely true
have we um
have we at any stage run past them
or uh asked for names to be fitted i
have no problem with what's here i might
add but it's just that constantly
that's put on there and i can see some
objections raised if
you know we get 54 streets to uh to name
and we get 54 no interests from uh
from uh uh manafenoua i'm not sure
that's correct
um yeah
it comes about i mean i mean basically
we present the list to the developer and
the developer chooser's name from the
list
i guess in the situation where we were
looking for a new name for the list or
the developer had had suggested some um
maori names or some some cultural names
then we would go to the to manufa and
ask them what what what their opinions
were of them as well um but yeah
generally basically it comes from the
last we i guess that's why it's in there
um because because
it doesn't affect them because
they come from that list situation have
have we actually been to manufenua
to ask them to put names on the list
no we haven't but that's basically the
um basically the government governance
team are handling
the maintaining of the road naming list
from now on so that's something would be
that that they they could look at doing
as well to add some more names um
certainly a possibility
to do
um basically we just present the list to
the developers and then they have the
opportunity to choose
uh names off that list and then we go
from there
thanks scott madam richie can i ask that
we do that please
yes i think we actually go to
and ask them
i think that's a really good idea and
i'm sure that they've got names um for
the that particular
you know particular areas around kaiapoi
that
would suit it far better than just
putting the name of someone on a street
they've probably got names already
for
areas i'm sure
okay so if we could do that um that
would be great
uh someone had their hand up martin
are you through through you met him
cheer scott in a previous report um
there's been a recommendation that had
been adopted to
uh name silverstream boulevard to about
where lot 90 is on the drawings um do we
not need to
um formally approve the extension of
silverstream boulevard further to the
east
otherwise the new road we're just
talking about won't have an intersection
with any road
so i'll just uh bring it up um
let me bring my map
um
if that's correct if it hasn't been
named then that would have to be
named as part of that yes you're correct
so if if silverstream boulevard yeah as
part of that new the new stage 8a then
that would
still still trim
would have to be extended
to include that yeah
so would that be to the intersection of
steed street
um
yes surely
yeah i think you'll find it well because
that's where it goes to doesn't it it's
the new corner the new roads going
through there
is that right scott
if we lost scott would look like it yeah
all right well that makes sense to me
martin i think you're right there
okay um any other comments
all right
well oh are we happy with the basting
street and bake street i'd like to
change one of those to waverly
can i
can i just do that by changing it
if you're moving it
if but
i will think bestings well leave best
things they're big i mean the banks were
over in chest street um that's a long
way away from here
so we'll make number two um waverly
street so i'll move back then that a
b
chair
yes just before we move out just in
light of martin's question
is it worthwhile adding um
the extension of silverstream boulevard
through to
wherever that is
is it worth adding that in so it doesn't
have to come back chris is that
something we could do
yes as far as i'm aware if you make it
as um
as d
you could then say um that the border
proves the extension of silverstream
boulevard
from x to x
okay is that what you were suggesting is
that you
i'm just saying it needs a name
well
yeah no that'll sort it all right so
i'll move um a
b one basting street to waverly street
c and d the extension of sovereign
boulevard to um
where it joins snead street
that's all isn't it yeah do i have a
second one
brent seconded by brent
um do you want to say anything brent
thank you no i think uh all logical good
idea of changing waverly
all right okay
um all right so all those in favor
against look
carried all right good thank you it's
very good
6.5
we've got this application again that's
been before so okay tell us about the
reasons for this being represented
seeing as we turn them down last time
yes um when this this application came
back onto my desk i did contact
the
play center
and i said
we've had this in september
and the board turned it down
um i
i don't think we should be putting it to
the board again i would give i
recommended that they put it to the
oxford board
because as you remember they're on the
border and they could apply to either
board
and i got a an email back saying
they had
changed the application slightly
the first application was for the mud
kitchen and bark for the outside area
and they
maintained they'd also asked for trees
i went back and said no
you asked for bark and mud kitchen there
was no trees in the original application
however she had
she was insistent that i present this
report again to you because she felt
that
um you would change your mind but
obviously that's up to the board
so i'm back in the room sorry i don't
know
maintain it dropped off sorry i had to
lock back in
jackie you're muted
sorry uh yes scott we moved um and we
changed one of the names to waverly
america i'm sorry we added okay
we added the sovereign boulevard
extension as well
silver stream
is waverly street okay so
okay
and and silver stream is going to be
to snead street
silver stream boulevard it's the
extension it's already silverstream
boulevard to where it used where it
could go but now they're extending it
and it's joining sneed streets
all right
okay
perfect cool
right so again
going back to six oh thank you stop
going back to six no worries
my computer glitch that's all right
these things happen
yeah um
you so i i can't see any point in
allowing um this to in approving this
grant it's the same as the one we
declined last time so martin wants to
say something and so does ale
no martin doesn't your hat your little
golden hand is up there al you want to
say something to you yeah just very
briefly i mean i think kaye's got it
right um we we turned it down last year
i'm sorry but i belong to a generation
that if children want to play in the mud
you put them outside in the rain you
don't you don't set up um
ruining the planet plastic gear for them
to play in the mud i'm sorry i i can't
buy into this
um brent
thank you madam chair am i correct kay
in saying that
they're also applying to oxford ohka
anyway for new bikes and scooters
uh i'm not sure about that but i do know
um they weren't keen to put this
application to oxford so it could
possibly be
sorry i don't cover oxford so i'm
unaware of what they're requesting at
any given time
on page 79 it says that they're actually
applying for both to us and also talks
with a hoka so certainly
that was for a previous
um item i think
you're correct in the last 18 months yes
yep okay
all right would someone like to move
right your hands up is that are you
moving
no
oh my move
i'll move that we decline this
application
so that's a and c i'll second that
you want to say anymore you've probably
said everything no and i agree so all
those in favor
aye
against carried
thank you
then we're on to 6.6 um the carpet tour
here we community board plan okay
yep this is um as you know we we
generally try and update these plans
once a year so that they're current and
um
a useful document for the board to
let the public know what they are doing
and what they've achieved
you will notice that there's quite a lot
of changes this time around
which i think is quite exciting because
otherwise people don't want to read it
again if they're just reading the same
old
every time
please note that
because this is
generally done in a publishing software
when we convert it across to word to
make the changes you'll you'll note that
the
formatting goes out slightly so that
will be fixed when it goes back into the
publishing items
so i'm happy to
take any amendments or suggestions from
the board
neville
can someone inform me why the um uh
councillors aren't on there
we are members of the board that are
there
where
you might have got a blank page between
them
i've got
10103 shows the board
oh no
no no
103 must be yeah why is 103 there
i thought it finished there but it
doesn't yeah the formatting issues i was
just talking about okay all right thank
you
okay very good all right so i'll move um
the approval of the
community board plan for the next for
this year
a b and c
oh martin you want to say something
yes ma'am share just a couple of items
on page 102
um
we have some groups there which um i'm
not sure whether they're still
appropriate
we've got the piracy and vicary street
cycleway working group surely we don't
need that anymore
no
no we avoided a lynching there so i
think we should take that off
very good well well spotted
and secondly the coilpoi town centre
uh plan review and reference group
i don't think that's ever had a meeting
so
does it actually exist
oh
well i've been to her but
i must admit
does it still exist then
i don't think it's ever made i think
yes yes
oh i've been on it
it's that one
it was goes way back sort of post
earthquake but it carried on for a long
time yeah there haven't hasn't been a
meeting for well since i've been chair
has been a meeting but chris might have
been to one
it was concentrated
it's contributed to the last ejection
what was that martin when we disbanded
the regeneration
meetings uh this this group was formed
it was a committee of the of the this
board
and the other one is yeah
so you've heard of the chancellor
no this was never had a meeting that i'm
aware of
and the other one is the kyboy signage
working group has that ever had any
meetings
yes that's the one that we're working on
these signboards
yes the hiss and the museum were part of
that and um
who was the counselor that you used to
come along um
bruce was that you phillip
you did have a counsellor that came on
i don't think it was me
no
um we had meetings in the early part
i have to say we haven't met recently
because the project
this particular project is almost
completed but it's certainly not the end
of the project at all
they the aim of the group is that there
are going to be signs all over kaiapoi
um as we can afford them their heritage
signs showing um before and
not before and after but how it used to
be and how it is now sort of thing
there's one by the bridge
that's the first one yeah
so no that's very much part of it
um but you if you're probably right
maybe that town center one doesn't meet
now that the um
regeneration sort of changed
well the committee was formed
when the regeneration committee was
disbanded
you want me to maybe it's not the one
i'm thinking of then
i met with one
for years um when i was the chair and it
was all about the town center
regeneration
i would have thought that's what i
thought it referred to anyway but we
haven't had a meeting for a while
okay i will leave them on there um but
certainly we could don't need the
prerequisite anymore surely no we don't
need that one okay
thank you
madam chair just one day because martin
raises a good point i just note on my
own one that i'm looking at now
um inchi sister city advisory group my
portfolio and there is actually
international relations
and i'm not sure what the
emphasis on inchi is with the kaiapoi
community board surely it would be
international relations as per the
portfolio but i stand to be corrected
yes i i would agree with you councillor
that i'll
i don't think that one should be there
it would be uh connected to your
portfolio on council rather than on the
board right
okay are there any
any other corrections amendments
no all right um
have we
moved
we've got you moved it we're looking for
a second
ah okay
so someone's a second
neville seconded by neville
a
b and c
all those in favor
against
carried thank you
right um chairperson's report um
8.1
the youth development grant the
committee for the youth development
grant meant lot not long ago
and um the one application that they
received for the funding that has been
set up for
youth development um the idea is that a
youth who's got a project um applies for
some funding but it has to be a
community-based project and the young
man
who applied he was a chiropod boy um
never once mentioned the community in
his application so
um
we actually haven't been able to give
out any money that was the only entry so
we had a bit of a chat about how we can
publicize this a bit better and so
one of the members the youth person
chloe betten is she's
organizing visits to schools and we're
going to try and publicize it a bit
better
to students
hoping that we can get some applications
because the money's sitting there
waiting to be used
um other than that um there's a new
exhibition at art on the key it's emma
thomas who ran the 2100 miles in 21 days
down from cape ranger to bluff she's
also an artist so her work's well worth
seeing
and um
the waimakariri arts trust have had
their first meeting
organising the hardware expo so
we're going ahead with that so hopefully
um we'll be back in a normal environment
by july and we'll be able to
be back in the swing of things and have
another good um event i think that's all
i've been doing oh the
macareli public arts trust meet again
and
since then there's been the changes
the email i sent to everybody explaining
the sculpture
it's now of course as we have seen it's
changed it's going to come to chi boy so
i'll be going back to the trust to
try and work with
through them and with
grant about a location for that
sculpture
that's all i have to report i think
so i'll move that
you've received the verb my verbal
report if i can have a second
thank you al all those in favor
thank you against karen
that is referred for information
public excluded report
madam chair can i just um
ask about this on can we chris we might
be able to help us can we receive a
publicly excluded report
or
a recommendation from public excluded in
public meeting
um i can answer that if you like
okay thank you kay
um these are matters for um
information you can receive it
in the open meeting as long as nobody
wants to discuss anything on that report
because you're only receiving it as
information
does that okay just a question around
that so even though it says it's in
public excluded that once we've received
it in public doesn't it become public
no no it's because it's only for
information
um this this matter has been raised by
jim gerard
several times
and the governance manager has assured
me that unless somebody wants to discuss
what that report is about it may be
received in an open meeting
okay thank you
so
does anyone plan to discuss anything in
it can we just receive it then and move
on
okay
so the recommendation is that the board
receives the information
a
and b
uh oh but she's looking hard
yeah okay so i'll move that a and b do i
have a secondary
i'll second it madam choose thank you
grant
um don't think it needs any commenting
at all all those in favor
against carried
thank you
right members information exchange um
martin you're at the top of my list on
the left there you can start
um i've got nothing more to add to the
written
section
thank you for sending that out that's
right good thank you
al
thank you madam chair just a couple of
things with my um indigenous planting um
portfolio hat on um
the the one of the two bridges in in so
in the west end of silver stream is is
um approaching um
um i'm going to say finality but it's
not the the the planning of it and the
funding of it uh uh
approaching um
the
project
um
with my arts head on
you've covered the sculptures we've
ticked off the white pad have ticked off
a mural
by a local artist on the
toilet walls in oxford that's going
ahead and that's funded out of oxford
not numb with no cost to the rate payers
the pose at the gateway to
pegasus are finished if you haven't seen
them they're looking pretty good and
hopefully that will not require further
financial input in the next 10 or
however many years
looking good uh the bleachers
have been we've put leeches in at the
softball diamonds which are looking good
if you haven't seen them pop down and
have a look
um
we've got a little bit of a
pr disaster at pine speech some of you
will know all my all of you will
probably know there was a shack in the
forest there behind um just behind the
sand dunes that's been there for a long
time and the pines locals used it with
their children with a bit of a
playground and the forestry have
demolished it as part of their operation
and uh the pines um
beach residents are not amused at all
and have gone ballistic on facebook
both tika haka and council did not
intend for it to be removed and
unfortunately there's nothing in writing
to say that although the forestry had
been verbally asked not to um i've
talked to rob hawthorne and he's going
back to the forestry to find out why it
happened so you may get a bit of flack
from that
but um basically it's not it's not our
fault but it'll it'll wind up being our
problem and of course being an illegal
thing in the first place we can't we
can't authorize this rebuild
um pegasus bay by law committee met last
week um
the
various things the um
the two or two a problem on the beach
has been uh was brought up again and
mike quant has been off talking to mpi
and then the
group of university varsity students
don't ask me why it's um at auckland
university but it is
coming to do a research project on on
the whole sustainability of the tour
tour
um the bylaw is under review sorry i
should have said that first
we're not we don't particularly want to
review it but we have to under statute
so vj's working on that
the um
data from the um
observation we ran at the karaki
car park um 40 000 cars a year are using
that car park now um and of those about
uh 25
are going past it onto the beach the
good news is the numbers using it are up
the numbers going on to the beach are
down and the and past part of that
survey the knowledge of the fact there
is a bylaw and rules is growing steadily
year by year so the whole basically the
bylaw is working well and everything's
tracking in the right direction yes we
still have dog problem and a horse
problem and a vehicle's in the sand dune
problem but they're the overall stats
are looking favorable thank you
madam chair can i ask ella a question
please certainly
well with regard to the karaoke card
pack i noticed uh down there the other
day that at the turnaround at the far
end huge potholes have started to form
is there a maintenance contract in place
and is somebody dealing with that please
not sure but i'll take it on board and
find out and report back to your rent
i'll send through a send snap solve for
the effects of use
okay
thank you
good idea okay thanks brent
um right neville you're next
thank you madam chair uh just on that
issue i've uh bri you probably know
about it around the delt park the new um
all the tar seal around there and the
new um neutral seal has weeds growing
through it as well i've seen through
snaps insult but nothing seems to be
happening there on that move i can't
understand why
um this new tower seal is so thin or
sporadically put down that we actually
have weeds coming through and it doesn't
make sense for brand new roads so maybe
chris you might want to um ask a few
questions of the right people around
that because it just doesn't seem to be
repaired and right the way along
um charles street and around there to uh
almost a hill street sort of thing it's
always got weeds coming through
anyway that's that's a question if you
wouldn't mind taking that up um
look the the thing i wanted to report to
you on um is uh
frisbee golf now um i
unfortunately what happened today was
that uh on facebook uh uh i think you
picked it up brent that there was uh
frisbee golf coming to coyote which
hopefully is not untrue
but that's a rather enthusiastic um
uh
creator of frisbee golf if you like who
has put out his own facebook
post
that um uh before we got to where we
need to go i have actually been working
with grant stevens
on frisbee golf um uh to look at whether
it can go in the domain or not
and the reason that i've been doing that
is that i hopefully hopefully
may have it funded
um so before there was a proposal we
wanted to get that proposal together to
come back to the community board with it
rather than just um put it out there
that we were we were looking at it so
um that proposal hasn't gone anywhere no
there isn't frisbee golf and kayaking at
the present time and the post's been
amended um to say that it's it's being
looked at it was just a
rather enthusiastic young man who
thought that uh it'd be great to share
it with the world which uh as you well
know in our system that doesn't isn't
exactly how it works
so that's that's really all i have uh
madam cheer for now
okay thanks neville very good um sandra
uh thank you um
uh
how's your tiara progresses and you may
have read in that excellent article by
jackie watson that
the council has applied to wins for
uh to make a link through from
claiming some old deeds land
on the corner of the revels road bridge
and we're working
also
to finalize access
along
the last property
past 211 lower kemp side
when that's actually done and i'm
hopeful that um
there'll be um something to celebrate
by the
end of
end of june
july um we've also got um 6 000 plants
to plant so we may have a public
planting
and interestingly ecan has donated
another 10 000 plants
and green space is just looking at where
these could all go um
because they've just um
you know it's come out of the blue a bit
but we don't want to say no so there's
that um
you perhaps will see tomorrow if you
look at the utilities and writing agenda
that there are
500 and there were have been 598
service requests for date drainage and
flood relief following
may december and february
storms
59 of those require detailed assessment
and there is new staff being taken on on
a contract basis to deal with such um
a wealth of
requests
um
of those chi point not surprisingly is
the top of the list
and followed by
the district rating area which as you
know is the
rate you pay twice for
and also it's the rating area that
covers the rating areas that aren't
rated um
and
at the top of the list there is
the other end of your ward which is
wooden sefton
and the quite a number of
serious flooding issues have arisen
there that's an uh
an area
where the drainage is rated by ecan
and it is
minuscule
drainage and minuscule coverage and it's
a flood prone area
so as your representative i attend the
um
sefton
ashley
annual committee meeting for drainage
work which was just uh
beginning of this month
um quite of several people
turned up there who had been flooded out
and i mean seriously flooded we're
talking
700 to millimeters to um
a metre of water through their
properties
so
begs the question about really um what's
happening and we had a discussion that
would end sefton and a briefing um is is
on the cards from staff about
what can be done
where we're getting uh persistent um
i've just seen something
yes so anyway um that a briefing's
coming up for for council
on that and you'll also note that
environment canterbury is
talking about a district-wide flooding
right
and i'm interested to know how that all
hangs together with what the council
does
um the district-wide flooding rate the
targeted rates and now a third one
so yeah
watch this space thank you
thanks amanda
um brent
thank you madam chair i've already sent
through my report order
so nothing else to add thank
you no okay
and philip please take us through do you
want to say anything uh just two brief
comments madam chair firstly creative
communities of which you'll remember
uh we have a round out at the moment
seeking applications for funding
because of covert the last application
round was
quite small
so we do have quite a a
stack of money available for
approved applications and it's art in
the widest sense of the word
um
secondly just out of interest building
consent
for last year
kaya poi was number two in the district
uh behind wood end and wood end of
course includes ravenswood
so i didn't really expect kyapo to be as
high as that um 194 building consent
which was ahead of rangiora and also
pegasus
so things seem to be ticking over uh the
building unit is still very busy
so i'm apart from that i've sent my
report through thank you very much
usually number one philippine building
consensus
ah we must be getting shorter land
neville
thanks phillip yes i had a good look
around silverstone the other day oh my
goodness the number of houses that are
going up in there it's just it's
phenomenal
there's
people that are living there already i
don't know how they built them so
quickly
okay right
actually
we might take over angura
with the new development and silver
stream so there'll be many units and if
they're all on separate consents um
we'll get back up to number one level
we usually are
okay right so then we've got um just
three
consultation projects that
look at their e-scooters migrant
experiences and draft annual plan
um regeneration projects well here we
are um
here's the martin here's that
isn't that what you're talking about
that you think doesn't exist anymore
but i guess the working group that's
part of it maybe hasn't met for but
that's um
that's what it was all about wasn't it
the town center
anyway
board funding update broad distance
grant the balance 3627
and general landscaping budget 25 430
both at the 15th of march
we don't have any media items i don't
think that haven't been covered already
um
although there will be
an opportunity i guess to um tell the
public about
the news sculpture
we still have some fundraising to do for
that so um yeah
it will go out into the media other than
that
it's just the next meeting
on monday the 11th of april at 5 pm so i
declare the meeting closed
thank you for your attendance
all right
everyone happy thank you jackie it's uh
in terms of the process if an artist
wanted to donate a sculpture
uh like i've got an aluminium sculpture
that we would we could donate to the
community what's the process
for doing that
um yeah just give me a call and
yeah